il tema scelto per l'expo 2015 è nutrire
il pianeta
e questo è un problema che noi in italia
e più in generale in europa pensavamo
fosse risolto fino ad alcuni anni fa
perché pensavamo che stessimo sovrà
producendo gli ultimi anni l'hanno
riportato drammaticamente d'attualità
perché c'è stata una combinazione di
fattori c'è una popolazione crescente
che cresce non solo il numero ma
soprattutto in fabbisogno alimentare in
termini di quantità e di qualità
ci sono stati degli eventi climatici
avversi che hanno fatto sì che i paesi
grandi produttori derrata alimentare
abbiamo diminuito le loro produzioni
e poi c'è stato il fatto che la crisi
petrolifera ha portato a utilizzare
quelle colture che non usate per
l'alimentazione anche per produrre
energia
tutto questo ha riproposto
drammaticamente il problema legato al
fatto che dobbiamo produrre di più però
non possiamo produrre come abbiamo fatto
finora
dobbiamo produrre di più ma dobbiamo
diminuire il nostro impatto
sull'ambiente
questo vuol dire che dobbiamo usare meno
acqua perché l'acqua un bene sempre più
prezioso
questo vuol dire che dobbiamo usare meno
fertilizzanti perché fertilizzanti
rappresentano un costo energetico ma
rappresentano anche un costo per
l'ambiente perché poi porta un
autorizzazione dei corsi d'acqua e dei
mari e degli oceani e dobbiamo usare
meno pesticidi e fungicidi perché questi
sono veleni sono veleni per gli insetti
e i fumi che non vogliamo uccidere ma
sono veleni anche per noi è un'equazione
difficile perché riuscire a produrre di
più impattando di meno non è semplice in
più se possibile dobbiamo anche farlo
migliorando ancora la qualità dei
prodotti che andiamo a mettere sul
mercato sia dal punto di vista del gusto
per il consumatore ma anche dal punto di
vista delle loro proprietà in termini di
benefici per la salute
ora come possiamo fare tutto questo
se noi ci guardiamo indietro vediamo che
nell'agricoltura il progresso è stato
ottenuto attraverso tre strade
principali
una è quella della genetica cioè andando
a modificare le piante attraverso il
miglioramento genetico un'altra è quella
dell'utilizzo della chimica utilizzando
prodotti chimici che aiutano le piante o
a produrre di più a difendersi dalle
avversità siano queste di tipo climatico
siano queste di tipo biologico quindi
insetti funghi batteri che le attaccano
oppure modificando le tecniche culturali
attraverso le pratiche agronomiche bene
se noi vogliamo imparare dal passato
quello che apprendiamo è che di questi
tre fattori quello che ha contribuito di
più è stato la genetica si stima che
oltre il 50 per cento dell'aumento di
produttività in agricoltura sia stato
ottenuto grazie al miglioramento
genetico
questo è un processo che ha iniziato
molto tempo fa è iniziato fin da quando
alcune migliaia di anni fa l'uomo ha
addomesticato le piante che oggi coltiva
è stato momento fondamentale
nell'evoluzione della specie umana
perché ha trasformato il modo di vivere
dell'uomo da cacciatore raccoglitore a
popolazioni stanziali iniziate la vita
sociale tutto il resto ma oltre a questo
questo ha fatto sì che in diverse zone
del pianeta quasi simultaneamente per
diverse specie coltivate siano stati
state iniziati dai grandi esperimenti di
modificazioni genetiche
perché le piante che noi oggi coltiviamo
sono molto diverse da quello che erano
prima che fossero addomesticati
dall'uomo sono estremamente diversa da
quelle che sono le piante selvatiche da
cui sono state ottenute qui voi vedete
l'esempio del mais il mais è una pianta
che è stata addomesticata circa 56 mila
anni fa in messico è stata addomesticata
a partire da una pianta selvatica che si
chiama teosinte la pianta selvatica è
molto diversa sia dal punto di vista
dell'architettura della pianta è una
pianta che ha tanti fusti che ha tante
infiorescenze maschili tante
infiorescenze femminili ma è anche molto
diverse una parte che più interessa che
quella che volgarmente
una pannocchia ma che in termini
botanici e più giusto chiamare sfiga
perché nel selezionare il mais per la
coltivazione se cercate di selezionare
una spiga molto più grande un numero
molto più grande di semi ovviamente e
molti più sedi per sfiga
oltre a tutto questo si è selezionato
per un altro carattere fondamentale che
è stato selezionato anche in tante altre
piante coltivate cioè il fatto che il
seme quando arriva a maturazione non
deve staccarsi dalla pianta perché non
lo si vuole dover andare a raccogliere
per terra con tutti i problemi che ne
derivano
lo si vuole che resti sulla pianta per
facilitare il lavoro dell'agricoltore
questo da solo è un carattere che rende
queste piante completamente inadatte a
vivere in natura perché il distacco del
6 ma indispensabile per la propagazione
della pianta
questo per farvi capire quanto queste
piante siano lontane da una pianta
frutto di quella che sarebbe stata la
normale evoluzione naturale
successivamente all'addomesticamento
iniziale l'uomo ha continuato a cercare
di migliorare le piante che coltivava e
l'ha fatto con metodi molto empirici che
si basavano su un incrocio e sulla
selezione cercando sempre più di
combinare caratteri favorevole in
un'unica varietà ci sono voluti millenni
perché queste metodiche trovassero una
base scientifica questo avvenuta
all'inizio del novecento con lo sviluppo
della genetica in particolare della
genetica quantitativa e una delle
pratiche sono state più largamente usate
quella che si chiama di introversione di
caratteri attraverso il re incrocio cosa
vuol dire che se io ho due varietà una
che è buona ma che manca di una
caratteristica che voglio portarci
dentro a tutti i costi
quella caratteristica la trova in una
pianta che però per tutto il resto delle
sue caratteristiche sfavorevole cosa
faccio la incrocio prendo la progenie
che deriva dall incrocio e lara incrocio
con la pianta buona e lo faccio per
tante generazioni ad ogni generazione
selezionando tutte le caratteristiche
positive della pianta buona ma cercando
di mantenere quell unica caratteristica
che voglio portare dall'altra varietà
così facendo il risultato che ottengo
è quello di ottenere una nuova varietà
che avrà un genoma che è uguale a quello
della varietà buona da cui sono partito
tranne che per un segmento del suo
genoma che quello che contiene il
determinante genetico cioè il gene che
controlla caratteristica positiva che ho
preso dall'altra varietà un'operazione
di ingegneria genetica è fatta però con
metodiche molto tradizionali di
selezione e incrocio
successivamente sono adottate anche
metodiche un po più sofisticate
una volta che si è capito che il
materiale genetico è rappresentata da
dna si è anche imparato che si possono
indurre mutazioni con una frequenza
maggiore di quella con cui avverrebbero
in natura e per fare questo posso usare
sostanze chimiche ma più comunemente
posso usare mutageni fisici tipicamente
radiazione radiazioni ionizzanti esempio
funzionano molto bene
questo ha fatto sì che storicamente la
ricerca sul miglioramento genetico
venisse accoppiata alla ricerca
sull'energia nucleare in italia era
l'enea che faceva questo tipo di lavori
che prima di essere lenti delle energie
alternative da quello preposto
all'energia nucleare ed è un metodo di
gray molto grezzo io indù commutazione a
caso metto le piante in un campo con
immenso una sorgente i raggi gamma una
bomba al cobalto e poi vado a cercare in
queste piante che sono state radiate
quella che porti la caratteristica che
mi interessa migliorare se sono
fortunato la trovo trova ad esempio una
pianta che diventa più grande ai frutti
più grandi questa sarà la pianta dov'è
avvenuta la mutazione che cercava ma
assieme a questa nel background genetico
ci sono state tante altre mutazioni che
evidentemente non hanno effetti visibili
e che comunque persistono in questo
genoma una metalliche come capite per
nulla raffinata però efficace per questo
è stata largamente usata molte delle
varietà di frumento duro che sono usate
per produrre la pasta sono state
ottenute in questa maniera
l'altra grande rivoluzione è avvenuta
negli anni 80 quando con lo sviluppo
delle tecniche di biologia molecolare
dell'ingegneria genetica
finalmente si è acquisita la capacità di
prendere
segmento preciso di dna e trasferirlo
dentro una pianta questo aperto la
possibilità a nuove strade alla
possibilità di introdurre
caratteristiche prima nella pianta non
erano presenti anche portato con sé
tante promesse che in parte non sono
state mantenute ma non per limiti della
tecnologia più che altro per limiti
della scienza genetica che sta dietro
perché ancora non si è riusciti adesso
questa tecnologia ad esempio a ottenere
piante che siano più tolleranti alla
società voglio farvi vedere un confronto
molto diretto fra una modificazione
genetica tradizionale e un ottenuta per
via transgenica e mi riferisco al caso
del colore del seme cioè seme bianco e
sam e giallo voi siete sicuramente
abituati a vedere il mais e come sapete
può essere bianco giallo noi oggi per lo
più lo vediamo giallo ma il mais
originariamente era bianco sia ancora
andate nei paesi dove il mais è usato
per l'alimentazione umana come in
sudamerica consumano quasi
esclusivamente mais bianco perché si è
ottenuto il mais giallo perché
all'inizio del novecento ci si accordi
che si usava il mais per nutrire gli
animali e deluso principale del mais
molto più importante quello per
l'alimentazione umana
gli animali nutriti con mais giallo
crescevano di più perché crescevano di
più perché colore java è dovuto a un
metabolita secondaria che si chiama
betacarotene che è il precursore della
vitamina quindi gli davo le vitamine a
loro stavano meglio allora cosa si è
fatto
se fate un processo massiccio chiamato
di conversione per cui le varietà
esistenti che erano bianche sono state
convertite in giallo e come è stato
fatto dopo aver trovato una rara
sorgente che dava il seme giallo si è
usato il processo che vi ho descritto
prima c'era le varietà buone bianche
c'era questa varietà che agronomicamente
non era buona ma aveva i semi gialli li
ho incrociati o prodotto la progenie e
poi loro incrociata sulla varietà buona
bianca
continuando a selezionare per l'alta
produttività e tutto il resto e
mantenendo se ne giallo in questa
maniera
sono riuscito a ottenere le varietà
gialle e 100 anni dopo abbiamo anche
visto quello che è stata la conseguenza
a livello di modificazione genetica di
questo processo cosa è successo è stato
introdotto un segmento di dna che sta a
lungo il cromosoma 6 del mais grande
circa 500.000 basi che oltre al gene che
controlla il colore del seme contiene
un'altra dozzina di geni quindi qual è
stato l'effetto che per modificare un
gene nella realtà ha portati dentro
altri di questi sono stati portati al
seguito di quello che io volevo andare a
modificare una conseguenza inevitabile
della tecnologia che è stata usata molto
più tardi si è cercato per ottenere lo
stesso risultato che era quello di
riuscire a cambiare il colore del seme
da bianco o giallo cosa che nel mais si
è ottenuta modificando un singolo gene
che quello che controlla il primo
passaggio che porta la sintesi della pro
vitamina lo si è cercato di fare nel
riso per riso ai semi bianchi
qui lo scopo non era nutrire gli animali
era migliorare la salute umana perché in
asia
nelle zone dove il riso è larga parte
della dieta delle popolazioni la carenza
di vitamina a porta a gravi problemi di
cecità infantile quindi si è pensato
così come è stato fatto nel mais
cerchiamo di farlo anche nel riso è
certo che eravamo 80 anni dopo
avevamo altre tecnologie non esisteva il
riso naturalmente giallo e quindi lo si
è deciso di fare per via transgenica
cosa si è fatto all'inizio e sono
inseriti tra geni non solo il primo ma
anche il secondo il terzo di quel
percorso metabolico e portala provina
provitamina a prendendone due dal
narciso il primo al terzo e uno dal
lievito quello che sta in mezzo
poi si è creata una seconda versione si
è visto che si poteva usare esattamente
la stessa variante che è stata usata nel
mais e si è visto che in realtà la terza
non serviva per cui il cosiddetto golden
rice che ha avuto ampia pubblicità anche
su time magazine che oggi viene
proposto ha al suo interno due già in
più che sono quelli che consentono al
riso di diventare da bianco o giallo
un esperimento dal punto di vista
scientifico molto pulito perché ho
inserito circa 10.000 base dna so
esattamente cosa mi serietà e posso
anche scoprire dove le ha inserite
questa è una delle paure che
accompagnano le modificazioni genetiche
per via ingegneria genetica perché molti
dicono anche se voi inserito in maniera
precisa un pezzo di dna non sapete dove
va a finire e dovunque vada a finire può
causare problemi perché va a disturbare
l'equilibrio del sistema
ebbene questa è una paura che non ci
dovrebbe essere perché le piante sono
quello che di più squilibrato ci può
essere al loro interno nel senso che il
genoma delle piante estremamente
variabile strutturalmente estremamente
dinamico perché sono ricche in pezzi di
dna che non fanno altro che spostarsi da
un punto all'altro del genoma due piante
di mais sono strutturalmente molto più
diverse in quanto non si amano e
rispetto allo scimpanzé da cui ci siamo
separati 5 milioni di anni fa quindi una
preoccupazione che in realtà non
dovrebbe esistere
cosa può succedere se noi ci opponiamo a
tutti i costi al cambiamento genetico
può succedere quello che è successo
nella viticoltura
come sapete le varietà di vite che noi
oggi coltiviamo merlot cabernet
sangiovese e via dicendo
sono le stesse che si colpirà in 200
anni fa non c'è stato miglioramento
genetico
qual è il risultato quello che vedete
qui nel grafico in francia la vite usa
tre volte più fungicidi tutte le altre
culture messa assieme a livello europeo
occupa il 5 per cento della superficie
coltivata e consuma circa il 60 per
cento dei fungicidi numeri schiaccianti
che non sono sostenibili
noi nel nostro istituto di genomica
applicata assieme all'università di
udine abbiamo pensato 15 anni fa di far
partire un progetto per creare nuove
varietà di vite da vino una sfida perché
il mondo del vino mondo estremamente
conservatore
che fossero naturalmente resistenti a
due principali patogeni fungini la
peronospora e oidio e l'abbiamo fatta
attraverso una procedura tradizionale di
in croce selezione è un lavoro veramente
faticosissimo perché è una specie che ci
mette tanto a riprodursi poi perché
bisogna selezionare per la resistenza
bisogna selezionare per una pianta che
abbia le caratteristiche agronomiche
desiderate e soprattutto bisogna in
faccia vino buono e vi assicuro che
selezionare per la qualità del vino non
è semplice bisogna anche bernie tanto
fra l'altro io ho dovuto soffrire questo
supplizio
comunque dopo 15 anni quest'anno siamo
finalmente arrivati ad avere delle
varietà che andranno in registrazione
abbiamo delle varietà che quando vengono
coltivate con due soli trattamenti sono
pressoché immuni da qualsiasi infezione
fungina quando la il normale varietà
hanno bisogno di 20 30 trattamenti
all'anno e ne abbiamo 18 alcune uva
bianca altre uve rossa che come ho detto
adesso sono in fase di assaggio in tutta
italia l'intenditore diranno quali sono
quelle più promettenti quelle meno quali
sono più adatte a certi climi ad altri
abbiamo un grosso problema se potete
aiutarci scrivete a questo indirizzo è
quella di trovare dei nomi vi assicuro
che i nomi scelti dagli scienziati ci
sono quello che di peggio si può pensare
non vi dico neanche la gamma di nomi che
ci hanno proposto i colleghi però adesso
vorrei farvi riflettere
allora ce l'abbiamo fatta vedremo sul
mercato le accetta queste varietà perché
ovviamente come ho detto al mondo del
vino un mondo conservatore queste benché
si sia partiti da cabernet da savignano
non sono cabernet sauvignon sono cose
diverse e quindi bisogna capire come il
mercato le accetterà forse le
accetteranno più mercati che non sono
quello italiano francese che i nostri
noi questo lavoro l'avremmo potuto fare
in due anni se avessimo potuto usare
l'ingegneria genetica con un intervento
che non sarebbe stato transgenico much
igienico perché avremmo preso lo stesso
gene che abbiamo inserito per incrocio e
avremmo potuto trasformare merlot
cabernet
il verdicchio nebbiolo tutto quello che
volevamo fra l'altro salvaguardando la
biodiversità non l'abbiamo potuto fare
perché l'opinione pubblica non lo vuole
ecco io credo che bisogna riflettere su
questo bisogna che ci sia una
discussione che sia scevra da pregiudizi
da ideologie
bisogna che ci sia una discussione dove
non me chi ha interessi di parte che fa
le scelte perché altrimenti non ci
possiamo lamentare se la legge sulle
frequenze televisive la fa chi le
televisioni le possiede e ricordiamoci
che in questo settore
chi si ferma è perduto e chi vuole a
tutti i costi tornare indietro come
molti in italia rischia poi di non
ritrovare la strada per andare avanti
grazie